bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission
direction l'espagne va-t-on vers
l'interdiction de l'avortement dans la
péninsule ibérique
le choix de la chaîne parlementaire
cette semaine c'est de vous parler de
cette loi qui pourrait limiter
drastiquement l'avortement en espagne
projet adopté par le conseil des
ministres en décembre juste avant noël
et qui devrait être discuté au parlement
espagnol d'ici deux mois
l'espagne revient tel 30 ans en arrière
une loi anti ivg qui annule la loi de
2010 celle là même qui autorise
l'avortement jusqu'à 14 semaines et même
jusqu'à 22 semaines en cas de
malformation du foetus
quelles seraient les conséquences de
l'adoption d'une loi aussi restrictive
pour l'avortement pour les femmes
espagnoles
que peut faire l'europe c'est ce que
nous allons voir dans cette émission
mais avant un tout autre sujet qui sera
le prochain président de la commission
européenne une nouvelle disposition qui
est inscrite dans les traités et claire
nette et précise elle dit que le
successeur de josé manuel barroso sera
nécessairement issus du parti qui aura
gagné les élections européennes qui
auront lieu en france en mai prochain
alors au niveau européen les partis
politiques s'organisent on est en train
on est en train de choisir son champion
et à quatre mois du scrutin ils sont
nombreux les champions
la bataille pour la présidence de la
commission européenne a commencé
lui il est à la tête de la commission
depuis dix ans et son poste fait l'objet
de toutes les convoitises
le 1er novembre prochain josé manuel
barroso cédera sa place après deux
mandats en tant que chef de l'exécutif
européen
à gauche le parti socialiste européen a
déjà tranché
si cette formation arrive en tête des
élections en mai prochain ce sera
l'allemand martin schulz actuel
président du parlement européen qui
prendra la tête de la commission
chez les verts l'eurodéputé français
josé bové participe actuellement à une
primaire concentre le belge guy
verhofstadt sera le candidat des
libéraux à la présidence de la
commission européenne
c'est un fédéraliste convaincu il prône
la création des états unis d'europe
à droite enfin au parti populaire
européen la bataille sera rude entre le
commissaire européen michel barnier
l'ex premier ministre luxembourgeois
jean claude juncker et le premier
ministre polonais donald tusk
alors question verra-t-on un français
après jacques delors à la tête de
l'exécutif européen
françois hollande pourrait soutenir la
candidature du français michel barnier
même s'ils sont de bords politiques
différents idem pour angela merkel de
droite qui pourrait soutenir la
candidature de martin schulz de gauche
mais allemand et oui la bataille pour la
présidence de la commission européenne 1
ses raisons que la raison ne connaît pas
alors nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
josé bové bonjour je vous êtes euro
débutent écologie les verts on l'a vu de
petits sujets vous êtes vous même
candidat à la présidence de la
commission européenne
mais chez les écolos vous n'êtes pas
seuls il ya l'italienne monica frassoni
les allemande rebecca harms et
franchissent cas jusqu'à l'heure chez
les écolos organise une primaire comment
ça se passe nous allons élire deux
porte-parole de la campagne et dans ces
deux à nommer une femme sera choisie
aussi donc le candidat pour la président
de la commission européenne on a essayé
d'organiser quelque chose qui est pas
facile c'est à dire une consultation où
chacun par internet puissent voter s'il
a plus de 16 ans et qu'il habite un des
états des 28 états de l'union européenne
donc c'est une consultation qui est
ouverte
c'est la première fois qu'on fait ça
donc on va essuyer les plâtres c'est
évident je sais pas combien de gens vont
voter ça va pas être évident parce que
pour sécuriser il faut voter numéro qui
arrive sur le portable ça c'est très
compliqué mais en tout cas on essaye d
ouvrir la question à tous les citoyens
on perd alors en quelques mots le
résultat 29 janvier prochain donc c'est
dans une semaine
en quelques mots lors quel sera votre
votre programme pour convaincre pour
voter pour vous alors je pense que
d'abord ce qui est important à dire
c'est que pour la première fois les
partis européens qui siègent au
parlement repères ont décidé de mener
cette bataille pour qu'il y ait une
légitimité la commission européenne et
ça c'est important
il va falloir qu'on fasse pression
ensuite sur les états parce que je ne
suis pas sûr que les 28 chefs d'état et
gouvernement ont envie de partager avec
le parlement européen le choix de la
présidence de la commission
mais si on veut qu une légitimité à
l'europe il va falloir le faire donc
pour moi ça c'est déjà le premier combat
si je suis candidat à cette candidature
c'est d'abord pour donner de la
légitimité alors connaît une europe qui
soit légitime par rapport aux citoyens
qui sont de plus en plus qui s'en
éloigne
glad et ça c'est la question la
légitimité ensuite la démocratie et la
transparence
on peut pas continuer dans une europe où
les conflits d'intérêts les lobbys
fonctionne la manière dont fonctionne
car ensuite il faut des projets comment
ils fonctionnent les lobbys s'est replié
une présence des lobbys très importante
au niveau européen ce qui est logique
puisque en fait c'est au niveau européen
quelque chose s'est dit si donc il faut
sortir de ces conflits d'intérêts la
façon on l'a bien vu sur l'énergie sur
le climat ces jours ci on voit très bien
comment les grandes compagnies
pétrolières chimique du ciment font
pression pour pâques connais un objectif
ambitieux de réduction de co2 là c'est
très clairement les lobbys qui sont
actionnaires il faut qu'on ait une
europe qui fonctionne dans l'intérêt des
citoyens et qu'ils soient capables de
mutualiser les néron l'a dit josé bové
le prochain président de la commission
sera issu du parti qui aura gagné les
élections européennes qui se dérouleront
en france le 24 mai prochain
donc ça va jouer entre les sociaux
démocrates et le parti populaire
européen votre candidature c'est quoi
une candidature de symboles de
candidature de principe
alors est-ce qu'il faut quand même
savoir c'est que au parlement européen
je crois pas que ça va vraiment changer
de cette fois ci il n'y a pas un seul
parti qui est majoritaire personnes à
50% des sièges +1 donc il va falloir
discuter et on va discuter ensemble
entre l'ensemble des parties on verra
bien comment on construit une
candidature qu'on proposera aux chefs
d'état de gouvernement donc il y aura
forcément un travail pour essayer de
trouver une candidature commune qui
sortira des différents candidats
donc c'est un débat pour nous ce qui est
important c'est de faire rentrer la
démocratie dans l'europe
josé bové et si je vous dis martin
schulz vous dites quoi point négatif pas
positif martin schulz j'avais il ya les
points positifs et négatifs
point négatif pour moi martin chose n'a
pas été capable de résister à la
pression des états dans le débat sur le
budget et il a cédé et donc aujourd'hui
on a un budget ridicule au niveau de
l'europe
je vous dit michel barnier point positif
points négatifs
michel barnier je dirais régulateurs et
en ce sens là c'est important niveau pas
que des gens aient envie de réguler pour
autant je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils fassent
le consensus dans son camp et la
candidature bové alors c'est quoi c'est
quoi l'originalité des des écologistes
dans ce jeu là mais je crois que les
écologistes
un ont toujours défendu l'europe on l'a
vu encore rebecca harms et et à kiev
avec les manifestants dans la rue pour
défendre les droits et les fondamentaux
de l'europe ça je crois que cette
première chose deuxième jour on aura pas
de sortie de crise si on n'a pas un
bouleversement complet sur la question
de l'économie
la mise en place d'une transition
énergétique et donc des investissements
européens donc on est pour une robe
beaucoup plus intégrée qui portent
véritablement la sortie des crises
personnellement vous êtes battus pour
rester dans le jeu vous serez peut-être
de liste aux élections européennes
alors moi je suis déjà candidat dans le
sud ouest et l'ouest du sud-ouest de la
france
c'était difficile à passer mais c'est
toujours comme la niche par excellence
et à la politique donc voilà ça y est le
sait quoi ya pas de prime au sortant
c'est non mais c'est que plusieurs
personnes sont légitimes et après ben
voilà il ya un choix qui est fait non la
campagne est lancée
je suis candidat dans cette primaire on
le verra si je suis une des deux têtes
de liste qui va être choisi le 29
janvier prochain
et puis là je viens d'une tournée à
travers tous les pays européens on était
encore à rome à londres à paris hier
soir josé bové alors une enquête récente
montre l'extrême défiance de la société
française vis-à-vis de l'europe 70% des
sondés de cette enquête pense qu'il faut
renforcer le pouvoir de décision de la
france même si cela doit conduire à
limiter les pouvoirs de l'europe les
français sont tentés aujourd'hui par
plus que jamais par une forme de repli
national ça vous inspire quoi
ça m'inspire qu'en fait les gens ne se
rendent pas compte de ce qui c'est en
train de se passer et je crois que
beaucoup de choses qui reproche à
l'europe
en réalité leurs proches à leur propre
gouvernement donc une défiance on le
voit danser dans le même sondage
vis-à-vis de la politique
en gros les élus sont corrompus les élus
en fait ne font ça que pour eux-mêmes et
ses accès à aucun vrai problème du
rapport des citoyens à la politique j'ai
l'impression que l'est beaucoup d'abord
à l'europe comment on peut changer ça
cette vision alain je crois qu'il faut
d'abord par l'éducation de repli faut
pas partir les choses concrètes
comment l'europe protège par rapport aux
normes
par rapport à l'emploi aujourd'hui par
exemple avec la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme c'est pas les
institutions européennes mais c'est à
côté
c'est un outil formidable pour défendre
les droits et au contraire pour les
élargir
donc tout ça pas partie d'un jeu
collectif
or aujourd'hui on aura pas de solution
sans être capable de renforcer l'europe
ca de renault en plus intégrés mais pose
aussi plus transparentes et
démocratiques
merci josé bové d'avoir accepté notre
invitation maintenant place à placer
reportage le choix de la chaîne
parlementaire cette semaine
7 vous parler de cette loi qui pourrait
pratiquement interdire l'avortement en
espagne
un projet adopté par le conseil des
ministres en décembre juste un peu avant
noël un projet qui pourrait être discuté
au parlement espagnol dans deux mois
la bataille entre partisans et opposants
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
s'annonce rude
notre envoyé spécial jean baptiste
daoulas est parti voir de plus près
comment ça se passe
reportage
au parlement espagnol
une guerre de tranchées va commencer
dans quelques minutes les députés sont
encore en vacances
mais la gauche a convoqué une session en
urgence le 14 janvier une manoeuvre pour
retarder la réforme de l'avortement du
gouvernement de mariano rajoy fait il n
a jamais retirer ce projet de loi aussi
en train de machiste que vous nous
présentez est impressionnant c'est reda
vous vous entêtez à ne pas vouloir
reconnaître l'évidence ce que les
médecins et des scientifiques constatent
à tous les jeunes derrière une grossesse
il ya une vie est derrière un avortement
il y à la fin de ses filles savaient en
2011 la réforme de l'avortement était
dans le programme électoral du partido
popular de mariano rajoy
un projet très restrictif l'avortement
ne sera permis qu'en cas de viol ou de
risque pour la santé de la mère pour
avorter la femme devra obtenir au moins
deux certificats médicaux différents
complication supplémentaire
le médecin qui délivre le certificat
médical ne doit pas travailler dans la
clinique qui pratiquera l'avortement
un casse à l'intérieur
un parcours du combattant à accomplir en
moins de quatorze semaines
concrètement il sera presque impossible
d'apporter ce que c'est ce projet s'est
imposé un ensemble de filtres et dans
traces pour que soient les femmes
renoncent à se faire avorter le procès
soit elle n'y arrive pas avant la fin du
délai légal
en 1985 la clinica d'athor a été le
premier établissement à pratiquer des
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
en espagne aujourd'hui les médecins
craignent un retour des avortements
clandestins
il y à des études très claire de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ou
de revues scientifiques très
prestigieuses comme hollande 7 qui
montre que les pays qui adoptent des
politiques restrictives ne font pas
diminuer leur taux d'avortement elles ne
font qu'augmenter la mortalité des
femmes en espagne
l'avortement est pratiqué depuis 1985
mais il n'est complètement légaliser
plus depuis 2010 un combat de plusieurs
décennies
pour cette figure du féminisme les
femmes espagnoles de toute glace et de
toutes conditions sociales voit bien que
l'avortement n'est pas un droit que l'on
ait pour toujours elles se rendent
compte qu'elles doivent continuer à
lutter d'après un sondage environ 80 %
des espagnols sont contre la réforme de
l'avortement mais le gouvernement
raffray y doit composer avec les plus
traditionalistes du partido popular
comme le forum de la famille qui n'est
qu'à moitié satisfait par la nouvelle
loi
il y aura toujours des millions de gens
qui revendiqueront une défense absolue
de la vie
une fois que ce projet de loi aura été
adoptée nous continuerons à lutter pour
obtenir une nouvelle modification et
aboutir à une loi qui protégera encore
plus la vie le débat n'est pas fini
un combat qui dépasse les frontières du
pays
paris manifestation annuelle contre
l'avortement le 19 janvier entre 16 et
40 mille personnes aux couleurs de
l'espagne et le patron du forum de la
famille comme invité d'honneur
non je ne télécharge en france nous
sommes heureux que la france reprenne le
chemin de la vie la loi de hollande et
rétrograde et profondément injuste aussi
injuste que la légalisation de
l'avortement en espagne en 2010 comme
l'espagne aujourd'hui la france peut
adopter une loi qui protège les femmes
aient le droit à la vie et sur la vida
la délégation espagnole nous montre
qu'on peut revenir sur une loi qui a été
votée une loi de société qui a été votée
et qu'il est possible de revenir pour
faire une loi plus progressistes encore
qu'il celle qui consiste à protéger les
plus faibles et les enfants on n'arrête
pas d'entendre les hommes politiques
dire qu'une fois qu'on a voté une loi de
société on ne peut plus la changer mais
l'espagne nous montrent le contraire
voilà c'est tout
dans le viseur des traditionalistes
l'avortement mais aussi le mariage
homosexuel ou la procréation
médicalement assistée des sujets sur
lesquels il existe autant de règles que
de pays européens
voilà c'était un reportage de jean
baptiste daoulas ça nous avons été
rejoints par ceux sur ce plateau par
inès ayala sender vous êtes eurodéputé
espagnol du parti socialiste européen
bonjour à vos côté nicole kill insel
vous êtes eurodéputée française du
groupe écologie les verts alors je tiens
à préciser madame que vous deux vous
êtes contre cette loi anti et ivg
nous avons essayer d'inviter des
partisans de cette loi les députés
européens espagnols du ppe
alors ils ont tous répondu non aux hôtes
où se trouvaient quelque chose d'autre à
faire comment vous expliquez ça inès
ayala sender là dessus mais au niveau
national mais on assume rep à haut
niveau à l'étranger cette loi contre
l'avortement
bon après je t'apprécie c'est que au
sein même du pp espagnol
il ya un grand débat il ya de plus en
plus de voir qu'ils sont contre cet
avant projet de loi que nous essayons
d'arrêter parce que justement il va
contre tous les éléments de progrès on a
réussi à voir avec la loi de 2010 qui a
lui-même réduit le nombre d'abord
d'avortement en espagne et qui a aussi
et c'est une unité intégral qui s'est
penché sur l'éducation sexuelle et les
tout ce qui est dans la prévention
alors justement on est contre et ce qui
est pour nous très important comme
c'était il ya des années qu'on
n'aimerait pas devoir
se rappeler que l'appui la réaction en
europe nous nous aide justement à
bloquer cet avant projet de loi avant
qu'il devienne une loi contre la santé
contre la liberté les droits des
personnes et notamment aussi
d'insécurité juridique pour les médecins
qui normalement nous aide dans cette
danse et aspire alors nicole kiil
nielsen ce sujet de l'avortement vous
tient particulièrement à coeur vous
m'aviez raconté en coulisses que vous
aviez décidé à l'époque de faire de la
politique sur ce sujet bien précis
l'avortement racontez-nous absolument
quand j'étais étudiante à la fin des
années 60 une grossesse non désirée
le choix entre l'avortement clandestin
avec tous les risques que cela
comportait ou bien ce que j'ai fini par
choisir parce que j'ai réussi à
collecter de l'argent auprès de mes amis
me rendre en grande bretagne où j'ai pu
avorter dans des conditions de sécurité
et à partir de là effectivement j'ai
compris qu'il fallait s'engager parce
que sinon c'était les autres les hommes
beaucoup d'hommes à l'époque qui
décident est pour moi pour le plus
intime finalement de ma vie c'est
quelque chose qui m'avait profondément
marqué et c'est vrai que je suis assez
désemparé et de voir qu'ils font encore
une fois se battre pour cette cause qui
remonte à tellement loin enfin on
al'impression vraiment que c'est une loi
archaïque et je suis de toute façon
totalement solidaire avec les espagnols
évidemment dans cette lutte contre ce
projet de loi
alors on a un chiffre le dernier en date
en 2011 118 1000 avortements pratiqués
en espagne quelles seraient les
conséquences de l'adoption de cette loi
restrictive pour l'avortement pour les
femmes espagnoles ces quads et des
avortements clandestins
oui mais surtout je dois encore rappelé
que même dans sept chiffres il ya déjà
une réduction de 5% de d'avortement dû à
l'application de la loi de 2010 deux du
gouvernement socialiste
et c'est évident immédiatement et ça m'a
touché énormément des reportages dans
les médias français
dans des cliniques espagnoles en
interpellant déficit s'élevait à
l'élasticité les conseils immédiatement
les femmes qui sont normalement
maintenance ou de la loi de 2010 ils ont
déjà dit ce qu'il sait qu'il
avec le peur de devenir bons plats mais
mandéens fortement clandestins parce que
pas tout le monde et surtout pas les
plus pauvres les femmes immigrantes
ils ne peuvent pas aller ailleurs et
c'est payé un avortement vie un voyage
même si aujourd'hui tout le monde semble
voyager mais ça veut dire que encore une
fois on tombera dans des avortements
clandestins avec les risques immenses
pour les femmes et même pour comment
dire pour le foetus futur et
deuxièmement aussi la nécessité pour les
autres d'aller avorter à l'étranger avec
tout ce que ça comporte
mais aussi l'énorme insécurité juridique
par laquelle ils passent là les docteurs
qui est maintenant comment dire ils sont
l'égalité qui risque aussi de trois à
dix ans de prison pour le fait de
pouvoir aider une femme et sous des
conditions incroyables parce qu'il ya
énormément des restrictions notamment
sur le choix libre des femmes qui seront
adultes alors irresponsables ceux qui
sont contre cette loi il ya ceux qui
sont pour cette loi à ceux qui veulent
restreindre pratiquement interdire la
possibilité d'avorter
je vous propose d'écouter à député
européen espagnol du pp 1 et un député
français de l'assemblée nationale on
écoute et vous réagissez juste après
il ya beaucoup d'européens
beaucoup d'espagnols qui ne se résignent
pas accepter la non protection de l'être
vivant de l'être humain le plus
vulnérable qui est le foetus
nous on a fait ce n'est pas un acte
anodin ça n'est pas en actes sans
conséquence c'est un acte qui est très
grave au sens du poids qu'ils pèsent
dans la vie des hommes est dans la vie
de toute la société et le fait de mettre
fin à la vie d'un être humain parce que
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit de ne pas être
considérer avec légèreté
voilà le député français qui disent et
la démocratie le parti majoritaire et
contre les ivg donc c'est normal à
l'ancien ministre conservateur espagnol
erraki qui en est convaincu les anti
avortement sont plus nombreux qu'on le
croit ça vous inspire quoi
qui ne ce n'est pas un acte anodin je
suis d'accord mais justement c'est
pourquoi la loi française par exemple
introduit l'éducation à la sexualité la
prévention la contraception et les vg et
d'ailleurs ces lois qui sont celles qui
étaient en application en espagne
jusqu'à maintenant et la loi française
montre bien que le nombre d'ivg et
diminue donc je ne vois pas la
justification de cette mobilisation
puisque grâce à une prise en compte
globale de cette question il y à une
diminution des désabonnements
contrairement à ce que certains essaient
de faire croire
donc je crois que là on assiste à une
mobilisation des radicaux de l'extrême
droite il faut le dire et de certains
coalisés avec des religieux des
religieux extrémistes également et qui
veulent remettre en cause les droits
acquis par les femmes depuis de
nombreuses années et qui
fondamentalement remettront qu'on
remette en cause l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes parce que ce dont
il est question c'est d'appliquer de
parvenir à une égalité effective en
europe entre les femmes et les hommes et
l'égalité elle passe par le contrôle par
les femmes elles mêmes de leur fécondité
et tant qu'il n'y aura pas se contrôler
et bien les femmes ne seront pas égales
des hommes nous le savons donc c'est à
une attaque globale contre l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes c'est
très grave
n'est pas d'extrême droite séance miss
de l'intérieur et les conservateurs ils
s'attaquent au mythe us bon mais en tout
cas et c'est seulement mais c'est le
pain en europe qui a appuyé la
proposition de loi de deux du pp
espagnol
je devrais dire à monsieur mayer irak et
dans son groupe qui devrait premièrement
convaincre une grande partie de ses
coéquipiers au pp espagnol qui veulent
ou bien qu'ils se paralysent directement
cet avant projet ou bien que l'on donne
un vote libre vote en conscience au
député du pp alors il ya c'est un
élément très important pour mais en tout
cas je trouve que pour pauvres pour
l'espagne on avait réussi justement à
avoir un sujet qui était qui n'est
qu'ils ne créent pas des problèmes et il
ya beaucoup d'autres problèmes beaucoup
plus graves dont sept en plus paradoxale
que les ppe maintenant met sous pression
les femmes et en plus les femmes les
plus pauvres parce que on revient en
arrière même temps de franco où les
avortements clandestins
c'était pour défendre plus pauvres et
les plus riches pouvaient aller ailleurs
tandis que le monde espagne c'est pas
1985 à 5936 une loi révolutionnaire je
vois la possibilité dans la deuxième
république qui sait après on se fait
alors qu'elle revient 30 ans 2 e oui ne
revient plus le oui on revient aux temps
de franco
comme je dis on a besoin de la
solidarité européenne justement pour
essayer de bloquer deux arrêtés
cette loi qui qui par l'adoption parce
que maintenant le pp est en train de
restreindre tous les éléments pour les
peaux pour les personnes les plus
dépourvus les restrictions aux actes
dans les hôpitaux dans l'éducation de la
santé des services sociaux
c'est le contraire je voulais vous
demander de la vie mais ils sont pas
capables de protéger la vie des gens qui
vivent déjà au delà des enjeux de santé
ce que c'est pas la liberté des femmes à
disposer de leur corps qui étend qui est
en jeu ce qu est ce qu on veut pas par
sanctionner un peu les femmes pour avoir
une relation sexuelle non reproductive
et ça va beaucoup plus loin que ça je
pense qu'au niveau européen l'espagne
tente j'espère qu'elle ne parviendra pas
d'introduire une discrimination entre
les sites
allez citoyenne européenne c'est
inacceptable dans les traités européens
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
elle est inscrite et depuis fort
longtemps depuis le traité de rome
donc je crois qu'il faut c'est qu'on ait
un contrôle social humain et mais je
pense que ce n'est pas gagné pour eux
parce que vous savez les associations
qui vont déposer un recours au niveau de
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
nous les soutiendrons d'abord moi je les
encourage à le faire et nous les
soutiendrons et je pense qu'elles
peuvent l'emporter parce qu'on est là
dans une situation qui est tout à fait
en contradiction avec les droits
fondamentaux tels qu'ils sont définis au
sein de l'union européenne écouter
l'europe
la patronne a pas trop ce mot à dire
c'est quand même une compétence
exclusive des états je vous propose
d'écouter cet cette femme s'était lui
espagnol qui vous interpellent à la
secrétaire national à l'égalité elle
vous interpelle mesdames les députés ont
écouté vous réagissez juste après
avec ce projet nous les femmes
espagnoles nous seront exclues de
l'europe en ce qui concerne nos droits
et nos libertés pour l'eau tantôt par
conséquent ce soutien de l'europe est
fondamentale
nous en avons besoin pour que soit
retiré le projet de loi
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire au
niveau européen ils essayent à la salle
de bon nous avons déjà eu un débat au
sein du parlement européen la semaine
passée astra débats houleux en kart wii
mais qui était plutôt curieux étaient
très très significatif parce que même au
sein du ppe du groupe et européens
les personnes qui ont parlé était
justement pour appuyer les blocus de
cette de cet avant projet de loi
je pense aussi que tout ce qui est la
présence dans les médias du sujet et du
débat justement en se demandant si
l'espagne fait un pas en arrière de plus
de 30 ans c'est aussi un élément très
important qui fait réfléchir le
gouvernement le ministre d'intérieur
est ce pour cela que nous tenons
énormément à que les femmes justement
européens nous aide c'est simone de
beauvoir qui disait en 1981 n'oubliez
pas qu'il suffit d'une crise politique
économique ou religieuse pour que le
droit des femmes soient remises en
question est ce qu'on n'y est pas là
mais oui bien sûr et je crois que les
expulsions européenne qui s'annonce dans
quelques mois vont être importantes et
il faut que les citoyens et les
citoyennes prennent conscience de cela
les droits des femmes les acquis ne sont
pas garanties il faut donc se mobiliser
et bien évidemment envoyé dans ce
parlement des parlementaires comme nous
qui défendront les droits des femmes et
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est à des enjeux de ces élections
européennes
personnellement ça ne vous pensez que
cette loi va passer en espagne n'ont
pour le moment on est ça veut dire moi
je pense qu'avec tout le support
européen des asocial des femmes la
ministre des droits des femmes sont des
manifestations qui sont prévues
jacquot mon avis à paris justement ça
nous aide énormément à montrer au
gouvernement espagnol que on peut pas
aller en arrière huit des dix citoyens
espagnols qui sont contre sept
changements 80% cinq ans à 80 % sont
contre et même au sein du pp comme jeudi
il demande que on arrête cette loi au
sein du bp ça veut dire les collègues de
monsieur mahieu relaiera alors je trouve
que comme comme tu disais justement
qu'il faut pour les prochaines élections
avoir clairement envoyé au parlement des
personnes qui sont pour le futur pour
les progrès des droits humains et aux
égalités hommes/femmes merci mesdames
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on
suivra bien bien évidemment ce débat
c'est la fin de l'europe hebdo la
semaine prochaine vous retrouvez nos
ramadi en attendant bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
connue du grand public elle pourrait
occuper le poste clé est convoité de
maire de paris